this guy's dreaming look
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Ryan Reynolds and I'm Rob
mcelhenney we're here with BuzzFeed to
answer questions I think while while
playing with puppies yep bring in the
Hound ringing the hounds ah
I love you little snuggy bunny oh my god
oh guys hello hello
hello oh my God poppies are my favorite
thing in the whole wide world and
they're Rob's favorite food yeah I
thought you said you hated children you
know puppies it was definitely children
not puppies though what have they ever
done to my sleep patterns nothing
[Music]
what God huh
leave me alone
can't you see we're in ecstasy here
oh boy or maybe it was when I came to
your house I spent some time at your
house with your family that was great oh
yeah Blake and the girls and we ate some
yummy food that was a good memory that
was a good memory I'm gonna have a great
memory of you smell like piss yes and I
love it just bad I love but it's okay so
much piss
[Music]
this should be like the national symbol
of Wales I feel like if they had puppies
like this in Wales as their National
icons they could finally take England
right in what way I don't know just like
Annex England oh just turn the whole
thing into Wales this is my work how old
are these dogs they are 10 seconds old
they're a half past gorgeous you are
just pulled out of there oh my God yes
you are
[Music]
there's this white puppy
it's this little beige
yeah get in yes this is much more
fearsome than a dragon right because
rexim's the red dragon this is this is
this is the one the white Labrador are
these retrievers oh these are golden
retrievers you oh yeah you bite me you
get in there let me see those teeth
my brain is so full of endorphins right
now from the yeah from the dog I'm gonna
say four four years Premier League no
problem
four years Premier League wow is that
even yours
this little oh ladder just emptied
itself right on the carpet I love it
over here oh yeah you're peeing right
here get on it yeah there you go yeah I
didn't look that's not a beverage no
don't do that you guys are not getting
your hotel damage deposit back no you
are not
[Music]
right
does Ted lasso have 65 puppies no I mean
you have to be like a serious A-list
star to just walk up and piss on the rug
at a junk don't you no shame this one's
eating like this you do oh yeah you know
what yeah rip them apart Disney's paying
for it bud
[Music]
I'm personally offended that I've never
been asked well it can be arranged the
answer is hell yes I have said I would
love to do a cameo drinking a giant bar
yeah guy number four Mac needs a
boyfriend great let's do it
my wife my wife will Lakewood that's
about it my kids will sometimes have you
know their little iPads they can
FaceTime us I'll always pick up then I
don't care what I'm doing
[Music]
whoa I think Deadpool and Frank Reynolds
Danny's character yeah they'd have a
pretty good they'd have a good time I
feel like prank Reynolds and detective
Pikachu oh yeah yeah or Charlie and
Pikachu that's true yeah DeVito would
have made a good detective Pikachu yeah
maybe better than you much better yeah
guaranteed guaranteed we'd be on
detective Pikachu eight by now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
just make a workplace comedy kind of
approaching it the same way we
approached Sunny which is like not
really a show about a bar so um no I
don't really play MMOs but I but I know
that like gaming is such a massive
industry and it just felt like a new way
into a story about a workplace and the
way that people interact in office
Dynamics and politics and it just so
happens to take place in a in a game
Studio
[Music]
I don't know
fun to do like a knock down drag out
fight with like
wall
it's got like some sass I think it would
be pretty epic to see uh Deadpool and
Thor oh that would be that'd be fun look
at that'd be fun it's just the one in
the bright colors
I know very dark I predict a like a
whole long life of crime for this one
right here
Superman
I auditioned for Superman 18 years ago
whenever that it or whatever that
iteration was 15 years ago the one that
um Brandon Ralph I don't think so I
think it was before that I think it was
the the sort of one that Nick Cage ended
up almost doing the Kevin Smith one
Tim Burton oh isn't it oh I don't know
I'm not sure I I didn't make it to the
director stage I barely got on the lot I
auditioned for Anakin Skywalker back in
the original like the original I
remember them saying to me that it's not
going to work because he doesn't have
blue eyes and I was like
[ __ ] you're like
creating entire armies full of mutant
robots yeah you can't change somebody's
eyes yeah I don't know I didn't get
beautiful eyes Rob thanks beautiful eyes
you would have made a great Ewok yeah
how would a very good Ewok yeah
[Music]
hands down Paul McCartney
wow Denzel Washington worked with them
for almost four months and it never went
away
what have I not yeah
all kinds of props everything yeah you
have every suit I think it's important
you you must have so much stuff yes we
have a lot of guys I took the whole bar
I mean I've set up a chunk of the bar in
my house yeah
[Music]
it'll be profane no it won't I it's it
won't be Deadpool 3 attack of the
puppies rated [ __ ] r
oh yes it's been discussed you know I
think it would go off Broadway like in
an alley somewhere but we have taken it
to we've taken it to Beacon Theater we
were way too busy for Broadway you have
no time for Broadway Broadway has no
time for me but I'll take it as I can
get it I've talked to Lynn Miranda about
it and uh he was very supportive
[Music]
foreign
for me
I would suck and I would be eliminated
in four and a half seconds but oh I love
that show
I think maybe Family Ties
for me
you see you're gonna go in a time
machine
yeah back in the 80s
ever oh wow whatsoever Mash mash Family
Ties Family Ties cheers cheers Seinfeld
I think Family Ties would have been it
for me I wanted to be Alex P Keaton so
badly wow I had a sweater vest and
everything yep just a young Republican
muck right now yeah yeah
oh that match would change yeah I don't
think much would change for me yeah I
don't know would you go to Disneyland
no
probably not no what is your celebrity
holding you back from I don't like
exploit it too much nor would I know do
I even think about it I don't know I
don't really think about celebrity that
man I don't know you didn't think about
celebrity at all this guy didn't think
about anything no he's not not impressed
by you that's good
thank you BuzzFeed and wear more wet
more pets I don't want to be too loud
because this this guy's dreaming look
these puppies are also available for
adoption final episodes of Welcome to
wrexham are coming up but if you need to
catch up you can go back to fxl
shut up
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]